Ah, porque esta importante conferencia es la
capital portuguesa la banda está con
muchos conocen este para dejar de pensar ya
salió de la parte de Transparencia de
Nivel de Alisson detrás del mío en este
el área no debería mostrar esto No lo sé en
diferentes en relación a que cada uno es varios
temas de esta mañana en ensalada de salmón
reportar donde nadie nace alla que
vio a su novio conseguir embajador
de la vida tu acuatica y enamorate
que la escala presenta Minas acompaña
aquí entre hace 24 años le gusta esto
Más chicos son campeones mundiales de surf
que me equivoque con mujeres por asociado
Hola Marcelo, es muy claro con un
cuatro metros de altura aquí buscar
Nazaré en Portugal y las chicas brasileñas
nos responderá en portugués de este
paseo para que podamos entender allí
pero gracias multitud por estar con nosotros
entramos 24 que tiene un area sembrada para ti
ella hay para
Wow, creo que eso es todo lo que sé, así que
resiliencia coraje pasión es
[Música]
fortaleza
tanta magia de belleza verdad que yo
Creo que también es algo que tiene mucho
en el oceano ahi que yo amo y
Le debo mucho a los océanos, cierto, creo
por eso me veo en esto
posición ahora para intentar
dar derecho
A los océanos mi tiempo mío
dedicación
porque ya me dio tanto y un mes de cotizacion
recordando a la cargadora Adela paralelamente a la
Pará nos roba esta opinión de no mujer
las cosas se quedaron ahí importancia de eso
educación para la protección de los océanos
es completamente necesario creo
todo comienza con la educación, creo
tenemos que hacerlo desde muy pequeños
los niños tienen que entender
los desafíos correctos que los océanos son
paso
los cambios necesarios que tenemos
implementar o dejar de usar
plástico de un solo uso, por ejemplo, cosas
que ya no caben en nuestra vida si el
la gente quiere seguir teniendo océanos
como lugar de salud fuerza magia
en
Entonces creo que la educación es esencial.
desde siempre creo que tenemos que
educar y educar a los más jóvenes o es
para que realmente entiendan el papel
de los océanos en nuestra vida
el y por ultimo que fue eso que
que santa es la conferencia aquí mira
si eres Esperanca, dale esta conferencia a
mi esperanza es que discutamos
suficiente sobre usarlos aquí se convierte en un
tema
derecho de prioridad porque creo que si
habla poco de los océanos
Sobre todo cuando se habla de
Protección ambiental
en la crisis climática es este año son
protagonista también, así que creo que el
seguir acercando la sociedad a la ciencia
la gran industria de los gobiernos es para
juntarse y realmente encontrar soluciones, ¿verdad?
por este problema que tenemos y que
no tenemos a donde correr
dar esta mirada para asociar con
Esther no tiene que recuperar el setenta por ciento.
cien del planeta Saturno está aquí más
esto de aqui muchas otras historias y
estamos aqui de la vendimia y en españa